in this capsule we will see our
first learning algorithms by
reinforcement assets then in the code
of passive learning what we
had to value the value for a
plan that was near determined prices
which was given to us in itself
learning by reinforcement not
this time particularly useful for
since in fact we do not know what is it
the optimal plan to follow
he does it if we want to develop a good
player in a game or a good controller
for a helicopter if what we are looking for
we are looking for the best strategy
best policy to follow for good
operate in a given environment
so learning parents inevitably
active in this case we do the agent
precisely must find this optimal plan
so we give him more a plan then to
from simulations he has to determine
his value
the dance what if the agent has two
objectives is to find the small plan
male and its value so that's what is
here we have to find the
plan so badly and it works value so
in this case v2 is what we put in
day as and when
learning is an estimate of
the value function for the plan
optima so in the case of the sentry box
adaptive dynamic programming
have done here we have two changes but
three changes to actually surveyed
very simple changes the first
is that now when we go
estimate the peace transition model of
the same mind knowing 1 6 1
it's going to be in fact for a state s
gave for more than one action so
in the passive coc because the action at
it's going to be necessarily kid's okay
to be necessarily the kim action is
dictated by my policy
actually in this way if I was estimating
may
my model other actions simply to
simply go for a single action
that is, the action of politics
in this case also the agent will be able
change action then try for a
self is given several actions
different so the other in that so
we will have to estimate our model of
transition for several actions
possible and we'll do it again
times from relative frequencies
as we do before, that is to say in
gold but in ten years the number of times that
I was going for an action to leave and
at s
so once I went to
the state expresses its being the same technique
of estimating the other difference it's
that we will apply worth a
regeneration by value on our
marco position comes we are going to have
so estimated our model estimate
of transition
so in fact what we will do is
solve the male equations for
find out what is the optimal policy
associated with my decision process
brand returns as estimated by my
model pay day springs has and at and
finally the last difference is
that now in hostage we will be able
choose an action and the policy to
any time that follows is the
policy that is associated with a sum of
future rewards expect the highest
whose maximizing ends here
according to our estimate of the model of
traction and parents so if we get
based on the worst codes we've seen
previously for the passive coop for
learning by pda to get
an algorithm that is active a
changes we make is that
now the action to which is returned
will not be politics I'm
supposed to follow
kim is dictated since their research
in fact the optimal policy I can
change the politics it's going to be rather
the action that maximizes the sum of
future rewards breathe second
modification is actually when I
do the liberation
when I'm going to actually estimate
my value board what am I going
execute her daisy as vale
authorization that will try to solve
the penman equations so to find the
values ​​of both is what satisfies
this equality here here at the dock so in
what if i find my maxi cie in
my system of equations and I have
use by the origins for the
solve and in fact there is in the grid
for young people since wind of change
who the third change that was
we will now estimate models
pressure for different actions
offered the pilot who had to see
work as well ie that
so I make a distinction too
I actually consider the action that have
been taken at the previous stage for
when I calculate the number of fake that
I reached because I created my
heel the project reaches the you so have
I will keep in memory whose fake
that I reach the state is this for a
action to the data and what happens
that's when I'm going to run their
gatehouse for data cleaning
the action offers varied from one go
come back on our same example play
with three states here so we remember
40-0 the possible actions c ar 2 and in
this meaning and a2 a3 and s2 remains one and at
terminal where I have no action possible
when I had instit upstream and
It's over
imagine that until now I have
in my essay went from 0 to 1 0 as 1
to 1 0 and that at any time I did
action at 1 to 1 and at three in the man
so at this moment it so now
I made these transitions there it wants
to say that my model my estimate of
my transition model to f zero if I
do the action to one is that with a
luck on two i will stay in 0 and
a chance on two i'm going to go to be
why because when I was 1-0
then I performed the action at one eye and
reviewed once I stayed at 0
then send 0 when I executed
it will be an intervention once I
have gone instead to and will be in
my system of equations the equations
field
I will have only with a practice 0.5
here I do the action at 1
I will stay a 10-0 by 2.5 I will
stay
I will spend later to
finish here this is where it's the part of
the demand equation associated with
the action will now have because I have
not done the action to 2 again made it
I do not know anything about glass she
is on other floors could do a
tradition so the term here finally vote
equal to zero because I claim
part of the zero-rate loan to pass
to any other state
same thing for s1 a care up
now I only did the action
at 3 so I only have a non-zero term
for the part associated with the action at 3
then for the action at 2 g here 1 0 and then
in population to 3 because I did
a good transition could also bring
at s 0 in fact the term if it's
just once the value in s is
here I saw 2 vs 2 equal to 1 in that
if I guess I know some pretty
reinforcement for each of the eight years
so now let's imagine that at this moment
this is the time for agent as0 de
decide what action to take on this
amazing in this case also what they
have to do is compare what is it
the sum of future rewards
so was hoping for action at 2 and
the action thus has both actions
possible if I find myself at s 01 to 2
because I have never done the action well
the sum of the rewards always needs
hope as currently estimated
on 10 0 because my model pull
is initialized to 0 for all
possible transitions
so here and for the action to 1 bat
currently at mons an estimate this is
of 0.5 a probability to go from 0 to
1,060 points 5 as pass quality and
2 0 have a what gives me an estimate
future rewards was hoping 2 - 0
point because it's smaller than
the sum of future rewards expect
associated with the action at 2 I'm going rather
this time choose the action at 2 to
the state hesitates so we see here that our
agent even change of action he goes
explore a new decision
do you have 0 for like actions
possible as a change
possible that would bring me closer
an optimal policy
so if that's how we move from
learning with green passive pda
active